según occidente y a juicio de expertos
esta rebelión expuso debilidades del
gobierno de Vladimir Putin Cómo se le ve
al presidente dentro de Rusia hay
divisiones entre las élites rusas
Bueno buenas tardes Es un placer estar
con vosotros vamos a ver el problema es
que hay tres posibles escenarios y aún
es pronto para que diese cuál de ellos
es realmente el que ha ocurrido todo el
mundo apunta que esta negociación que ha
habido por parte lucashenko para evitar
este columna de 50.000 personas que
avanzaban hacia Moscú que no es
suficiente para tomar una ciudad como
Moscú y su ejército era más que nada una
toma llamada de atención a Putin una
llamada de atención lo que se llama en
ruso más quirova para intentar generar
que Putin tuviera la necesidad de
cambiar tu doctrina militar y su visión
más agresiva hacia la Guerra de Ucrania
la otra vertiente es que evidentemente
está apoyado por algunos oligarcas rusos
del también lo es es un millonario Ruso
y por tanto estaría buscando una
beneficios económicos en el doombat en
la zona de Bielorrusia fronteriza por el
donbas que Putin no le habría ofrecido y
el tercera vía que es la menos probable
es que realmente frigoyen hubiera
traicionado a Putin cosas altamente
improbable y decidiera pues quitarle del
gobierno con un golpe de estado algo que
sería muy difícil teniendo el control
que tiene Putin sobre el fsb y el resto
del ejército ruso 50.000 combatientes no
es suficiente para tomar Moscú y tomar
todas las ciudades importantes de Rusia
Pero antes de avanzar con varios temas
que ustedes ya ha tocado con esto fin a
la imagen Intocable y lo digo entre
comillas que se tiene sobre Putin
No todo lo contrario esta imagen de
Putin ha salido fortalecida porque ha
logrado
que también es otro dictador todo
tocatra ha logrado detener esa supuesta
rebelión dándole algo algún beneficio
aging que le haga calmar declarando que
no va a ir hacia Rusia sino quedar en
Bielorrusia por tanto de nuevo se
reafirma la posibilidad de ver esto como
una línea económica una línea de
estrategia económica de apoyo a pregojin
en sus intereses económicos en
Bielorrusia y en la frontera con Ucrania
precisamente esta era uno de los temas
que queremos tocar Qué papel juega aquí
belarusó exactamente porque el
presidente Alexander lucaschenko se puso
al frente de una situación que le
corresponde directamente a Vladimir
Putin
precisamente porque lucachenko es un
Aliado piel férreo de Putin lo ha sido
siempre alguien incluso ha determinado
que no hay mucha diferencia entre Rusia
y Bielorrusia Más allá de pero menos
nombres y cuando un dos grandes o dos
políticos intentan llegar a una solución
y ninguno de los dos puede dar marcha
atrás porque significar una pérdida de
Liderazgo por ambas partes buscan un
tercero el que les dé esa capacidad de
de conexión no lo ocurre lo mismo entre
por ejemplo Ucrania y Rusia cuando China
o la India o incluso la propia Unión
Europea intercede para ver qué tipo de
acuerdos puede llegar para eliminar ya
la guerra civil que hay pero recordemos
que hasta que ordenó retroceder el
avance de Wagner hacia Moscú no enfrentó
casi ninguna resistencia y tropas de
emergencia incluso debieron ser llamadas
para defender la capital Cómo
interpretar esta aparente falta de
preparación militar
Pues porque nadie pensaba o nadie se
creía y precisamente es lo que favorece
la imagen de una falsa bandera o una
proyección de más Quiroga el hecho de
que nadie se pusiera en oposición hasta
columna de blindados y de soldados hacia
Moscú significa una acción escénica es
más partidario de una acción escénica
pero que es una acción militar y nadie
se pone en intercesión de una columna
militar esas características que genera
un riesgo de seguridad nacional una de
dos Pues porque no hay milicia no hay
tropas cosa que no es el caso o bien
porque es una cuestión orquestada o más
o menos orquestada el secretario de
estado de Estados Unidos señor corcho
Anthony blinquen dijo que las
consecuencias de lo ocurrido se verán en
las próximas semanas o meses cree que la
gobernabilidad de Putin puede estar en
cuestión hacia adelante
no más bien lo que estaba refiriendo si
leemos la totalidad de su discurso Es
que esto provocará un acercamiento a las
necesidades de las negociaciones que ya
están en marcha por parte de Ucrania y
por parte de Rusia de manera indirecta A
lo mejor un tercero en discordia un
cuarto en discordia puede ser también el
Bielorrusia y los aliados indirectos de
Rusia como pues del China o ese de Irán
o puede ser la India por tanto al final
Como se está viendo incluso cuando Ahora
se ve las necesidades de economía para
reconstruir Ucrania eso significa que se
acerca probablemente estadísticamente en
un escenario de que se acerque a una
reconstrucción del país y por tanto una
participación en el país uno no se pone
a reconstruir un país y previamente
tener la previsión de un acuerdo a corto
medio plazo bueno Y finalmente qué cree
que va a pasar con la relación entre
Rusia y el grupo Wagner
Bueno al final el grupo Wagner ya no es
solo una milicia ya no solo es un
ejército privado sino es un elemento
militar que tiene su propia herramienta
de tecnología militar su propia
tecnología de inteligencia Y quizá a lo
mejor se quede posicionado como siempre
deseado pero más apoyando los intereses
de Bielorrusia la frontera rusa con el
donbas que incorporarse a lo que es la
milicia normal escrito normal ruso qué
va a ocurrir pues va a ocurrir que va a
aumentar su poder si se llega a un
acuerdo Voy a encontrar su poder en esa
zona elner el oligarca va a más
poder económico más poder político más
poder militar va a controlar la zona
militarmente subordinada a los intereses
evidentemente de Rusia de Putin pero
donde Putin ya no se va a meter tanto en
Ucrania ni se va a meter tanto en lo que
es el dogmas sino que lo será lo hará
perdiendo en su lugar por lo que su
imagen quedará más o menos salvada a la
hora de llegar a un acuerdo puesto que
no será el que llega un acuerdo sino
será otro